what's with the jeans so I got this song
that you sent me yeah you did
oh we're gonna do that now I think so my
god I'm so excited I've been holding off
watching it cuz I wanted to watch it
with you the first time so I haven't
actually watched a lot of these ok
because I wanted it to be a surprise
this is um I'm so excited our man we've
we've played him on the show before
his name is does he have coming his
balls he's got coming his balls name is
Nick Hawk if you don't know he's amazing
he's one of the main hoes on the show
gigolos and it's so much Nick is he's
you know he's obviously he's the hardest
worker in the room I'm more competitive
it's very competitive I'm in the gym
seven days a week takes care of himself
basically really goes after it as a ho
but on top of that he's also rapper I've
been working on my raps and as a rapper
even on the show he got called out by
one of the other hoes
or VIN yes hey hold on just you know
he's from gigolos do we say that yeah
yeah he's super airbrushed here by the
way yeah I mean that's really no I'm
sorry those tattoos are this shitty in
real life too
yeah but they've also airbrushed or
whatever waiting real-life how do you
know because he had come in his balls
and I found it you know um you know I've
seen a TV show they can't do it for TV
every week look at it look at this mess
what the fuck it look way crazier now
what is that it's way crazier is that a
cover-up like he had some swastika no
it's like just wants a good I don't know
drinking too much coffee what like like
cover up those swastikas if you're gonna
be home
I'm gonna ask my cousin Julie Julie
Lissa's the show Julie what the fuck
like why why this mass it doesn't look
good it can't be can't be the primary
tattoo you know yeah looks fucking
tissue watch it my favorite no she
listen to our show though so maybe
she'll - I gave a so it's so much Nick
Hawk man like baked Nick Hawk let's see
okay I can tell you like I'm not I just
I hate on his level of he just fronts so
hard like no it's my yeah it's boring I
don't know you can't really do i yeah
yeah yeah and he's got his little nip
nip pierced and oh yeah yeah yeah it's
it's a lot man
the guy's a lot I think when men are
this fit personally for me it's very
effeminate
it's very vain and a feminist what I'm
talking about no I'm serious
and I'm not just saying that because
you're not to be a people pleaser here
but I'm serious it's not attractive to
me well it's not just being in shape
it's the way that you present how you're
in shape it's vain yeah yeah yeah it's
wanting to be fit but like this this
nonsense is ridiculous you're a
ridiculous man oh my life oh my a lot
yeah earlier shots sure anyways this is
now a word you're not focusing just on
Nick yeah I mean look tattoos you know
themselves are not lame this guy is kind
of we want to talk about his new song my
fuck this actually came out fucking last
week so we yeah we played yeah I know
we've played breaking this guy damage
we're breaking breaking a sweat the name
of this song if you listen a few
episodes back I don't never the episode
number we could look it up we we talked
about his rap battle with VIN that we
played on the show that they were on
gigolos so anyways this came in it's a
song that he's put out it's called
breaking a sweat I'm sweating it will do
I'm so embarrassed for him already
well you shouldn't be I think we should
legitimately give him a shot and let the
listeners decide whether or not this is
a good song okay I was like radio
stations do that
like is it hot or not like call us let
us know you can't really call us but you
could certainly let us know you can
certainly comment on YouTube on the
video itself and let let a brother know
if he's on alright so here it is that's
court okay oh my gosh shit
we gonna swim hold on Olin I gotta get
ready you ready here we go okay
holy shit yeah break me I can't be broke
any sweat in those balls oh man look
well we're all wondering neck is where's
the come so wait where's the video I
thought we were gonna see some visuals
and I'm upset that I hope he makes a
video for breaking a sweat but it does
look like he has a bunch of other songs
I'm cool I'm ready I'm ready are you are
you gonna you want to get into all of
them alright this song what's the
verdict on breaking this way that's
terrible it's really it's terrible you
really this is a this isn't your best
work this is a really bad song but in
Nick's defense you buy an album a lot of
times you go sure you know it's an
accomplished musician and you say yeah
this isn't their best song maybe this
not maybe not this number maybe another
number
what about born to be bad sure it's got
eight views breaking a sweat is 20 and
this is a wannabe bad huh it's like it's
kind of an original premise let's see if
wannabe bad is is good okay I'm so
embarrassed already for him what part
ten seconds in it's better than breaking
a sweat
yeah this is better than yes it's very
emo you can't blame me
I keep hearing these voices screaming
Poli and I lifted and dangerous all
right yeah is it me or is is it off
two-timing like he raps not in time when
there's a lot that's off yeah yeah okay
sir is there an actual video no these
are all just the songs
there's gigolo four views four months
ago I was four groupie bitches step up
what do you want to hear I'm out of this
world we fight it's up to you well look
leave leave with me no tipping and
sipping has a hundred and three views
that might be the song of the album is
that the breakout hit it could be if
it's got 103 views this is the last one
okay okay it hurts my soul I think we
should yeah we should give it a break
after this so this is our last shot
we're gonna go with the highest viewed
song on the album Tiffin and sip and
let's see what happens
it's not good it's better than the other
two songs it's not better than for those
26 seconds it was you know it's really
hard to do
what's that is to have it know to have a
video up for four months on YouTube and
only have two views that's actually
really hard there's not a lot of videos
that have such a low view count and
they're able to have two views and it's
been up for four months even someone
stumbles on it accidentally
it looks like it's his page he doesn't
have he doesn't have a good cadence
voice for rapping he isn't good at
actually writing lyrics yeah and this is
a bad path for him dude it's not good
can I tag Matt I'm gonna throw it out
here yeah I he's failing yeah
do you see how there's like 12
personalities of Nick Hawk in that yes
that's the problem the guy doesn't know
who he is a stands for if you watch the
show - he'll show up at the bar like
this guy in the middle right you don't
know who this guy is the next day he
feels like this right yeah I know he
doesn't know he's confused that's all
right he needs to pick and identify
people a while sometimes yeah well yeah
yeah yeah yeah the thing is Nick who do
you think you are I am something to
think about right
yeah so I'm to think about thing to
think about so I have this to show you
life was pretty cool a confused young
man yeah man that's something
something's wrong everything here it's
all bad thanks for taking that off I
feel better now like it makes me feel
weird
I feel comfy all his yeah I feel his
pain or something I don't know
yeah I feel like something slow